こんにちははじめた像です今日はこちらサウナ式辞という静岡のサウナのお店に来て
おります
24時間年中無休で営業しております
ここですねなんと奇跡の水ボールを噛んじゃっぱ奇跡の水風呂と言われているほどです
ね
サウナの聖地と言われていればしてみてくださいこの
有名人芸能人の
社員の数本当にすごいサウナの場所なんですけども
サラダでよく聞くととんど整ったという言葉があるんですけども整うって
どういう意味なんでしょうか
今日はそんなとどのうサウナで整ったっていう意味をみなさんにわかってもらうために
私はじめ殺王のサウナの1日の1日じゃねえは普通に一時間グレード
1時間外のサウナでやっていることをみなさんにご紹介したいと思います
血が入ってますねあの本田バスタオルも突っ込んじゃだめだし海パンもダメなんです
けども今日特別に許可をもらいました
あのねでちゃいけないものが出るとダメなんでですよねここだけ共感いただいて
させていただいております
それでまずはしっかりと水を塗りますし記事はですね
天然水なんで水がすごい体にいいですよごくごくと飲んでおります
そして水をしっかり飲んだ後にサウナルーム b
入ります
はいっ
今日ははず目社長の
合うなーるディーン動画になっております人それぞれ
ルーティンが違うと思うんですけども私の
独学の我流のサウナルーティンですぜひ見てってください
参考までに
というわけでこのサードの特徴は水風呂ですこちらですね天然水出てきておりまして
めっちゃくちゃ体に良いんよ星のベルよ
水風呂は飲んじゃダメだけど水風呂のベル4でこちらが sound room 2
種類あります
片方がフィンランドサウナという一般的に4から3打でもう片方のこちらの薬草サウナ
ここがですねあの海
てもらって分かると思うんですけど削りの量
水蒸気の量をみてくださいこれ
爆発いいですよ
本当に熱いんですどれくらい熱いカーマンのちほどを見てもらうとして
ここから僕がいつもはサウナに入ってからにするか持っていきましょう
まずはすぐシャワーを浴びますはい
体をちょっとだけ洗って感じだけも払っちゃう
で歯磨きもこのマークしちゃいますどうせ汗かくんですってまでいっぱい取れずキレイ
な状態でさらに廃炉ということで体
した後に
このままサウナに入ると水滴と姓をビタビタってなっちゃうて他のお客様に迷惑になら
ないようにしっかりと水を拭き取ってからさあ軍がいます
他はもう迷わずや[ __ ]さんが強い方の火力です
すごいんですければもうめっちゃのこれいってっ
行ってみないとわからないんですけどそこらへんなさあ何と次元が違うくらい暑いです
よ
クリートっ
いいですぐありますと
本当に暑くて汗が止まらなくて
あの何が楽しくて俺も言ってるかわかんないんだけど苦しいんですよ
だいたい僕5分から10分ほど入ります
あの体調と相談して入ってます
きついときは五味子が的な10分でこの汗の例を見てください
もう結構限界でもうやばいですよん
いやだ出たい出たいっていうところ好きでございます
そこを抑えてでてこの汗の量もうもう耐えられないんですよでもなんか変な達成感が
そこにはあるです
もう限界
ゆうげんかいの中水風呂水風呂ってもうあつってきてすぐ水が入るのをぐっとこらえて
このまま入っては駄目だねぇ
ということで汗をしっかり落としてから水風呂に入りましょうあ34回頭とかに
しっかりかぶって味をちょっと起こして
林正明に注意して入ってみましょう遊び来ちゃダメだしたければいけません
この後に入る水風呂が最高なんですよもう
特急深呼吸が出来るから本当にスーハースーハーしててめっちゃ草木も作って
水風呂なのになんか
あったかく感じてくるんですよ二木ともう変な感覚に陥っちゃうんですけども
ちょっと入った後に馬の気持ちいいのは外に出ます
でここからがサウナの醍醐味です座ってぼーっとします
この動作一番大事ですってこうやってるとですねなんかだんだんだんだん気持ちよく
なってきてほしい
意義なふわふわ感に襲われてしまいますさあ皆さん
左右な通われてる方ってこれを目標に入ってるんだと思います
本土で何か首がだんだん翌日赤で僕気持ちよくなっちゃったになって
時間が
さらに言ってる意味なのかも知れませんそしてそのまま2セット目に入りますまた暑い
んですけどそこをぐっとこらえて入ります
ほんとに辛いんでこれはついて
と出てきても限界もうほんとに
そしてまたすぐ入る水風呂でいきます
で休憩でもまた行きますこのぼーっとしてるの本当にもついて蘇生する3 set 目
入りますと大体ですね僕は5分から10分入ってこのギリギリまで耐えられるところが
入って
水風呂に第1分から2分ほど入れます
ほんと気持ちいいそう
であの待っていること休憩2もだいたい多分2分から5分では今っているのかな
で北3 set 目ぐらいからすると中頭がふわふわして心臓バクバクの脳みそ
グァングァンになってきて展示を見てるとなんかグァンがする人10%増加
これ弟 no と言います
なんかととのような感覚が僕もちょっとうまく設定できないんですけどだいたいこんな
感じ
んですというわけで動画の中ではカットしたんですけどもしっかりと水分補給をし
ながら
水風呂さんだ楽しんでみてくださいこれが私肇社長流のサウナルーティンです
これが正しいか分からないんですけど僕はこれが気持ちいいです皆さん本当にこれを
参考にしてもいいしも我流でもいいのでぜひ左右の気持ちよさを体感してみてください
じゃあな
ん
[音楽]
mood ん
ん
ブーフん
[音楽]